I am a lover of language I use language
to tile reality to clothe reality and
description and I language therefore I
become I believe the world is made of
words and if you know the words the
world is made of you can make of it
whatever you wish together one of the
coolest notions I've ever come across
about the trends formative and
transporting power of language is the
notion that words are not just
descriptive that words in fact are
generous
hold that in mind for a moment by a
friend that the use of language the
words you use to describe reality can in
fact engender reality can disclose
reality words are generative and so
people often ask me how do you memorize
why do you memorize so many quotes cuz I
do man they are the wallpaper of my mind
is full of prose and and I don't know by
what act I actually put them into memory
but I can tell you that the reason that
I love to recite quotes is because I
believe that the quotes that resonate
the ones that give me goosebumps the one
that make the hairs on the back of my
neck stand up our incantations they are
spells right there's a dream
and a sorcery that is employed that is
deployed through language to speak is to
enact an intent ation right so my
favorite quotes are these magical
incantations and as I recite therefore I
become I recite therefore I become that
makes perfect sense right
this ecstatic articulation and empowered
vocalization makes us what Walter
Benjamin calls enraptured prose beings
raised to the highest order we create
and perceive our world through language
we think reality into existence through
linguistic construction in real time we
are made of language and this concept is
instantiated even in our biology DNA is
code we are alphabetic all the way down
our genes are software programs even the
material world
is made but um Adams programmed into
certain instantiation
[Music]
Makenna was right
the world is made of words and if you
know the words the world is made of you
can make it whatever you wish to take
responsibility for this metaphysical
tool employ language with discernment
and intention and agency and become an
author ooh yeah